hello people I am Greg I am John again
where I rec Horseman has been part of
our patron page for quite some time and
a couple months ago I was like I'm gonna
get a real rejects tattoo I'm like okay
sure people say stuff and then he's like
no I'm gonna get it I'm gonna get it and
then he eventually scheduled it and I
said here's our email you sent me photo
of it when you're done yeah to prove it
and apparently he's gotten his tattoo of
the real rejects that we have yet to see
it are we gonna do a reaction to a since
several emails and I saw that on
Instagram
I am tagged in one of them but it's time
to check it out and see what's going on
here so first email comes in says I'm
here forgot you're supposed to have a
full stomach before again your tattoo
cut to me passing out look at that
little tease in the tattoo shop - parlor
action some nice waiting room chairs
it's good I'm glad you're comfortable we
don't need a need to talk about all this
is a breakdown right down yes it brief
ringin picture he sent over I want to
get to the tattoo all right 5 minute
break before color oh my god it's
starting to happen whoa that is HUGE
whoa all right this is first stage right
yeah oh my god it looks painful yeah I
mean I've heard your bicep is is one of
the gentler areas to get tatted up but I
I've like this is so surreal because
it's now becoming real to me I never
fully thought I would have to comprehend
the idea that somebody would get their
logo permanently tattooed upon their
skin it's like I've heard people
describe this feeling in the past as
being very surreal and it totally is
okay he's got a little video here for us
let's check this out oh snap
[Laughter]
the sound to always rattles my teeth a
little bit final result is this the
Instagram only make sure it's the
Instagram one is it backwards well
because the mirror says tattoo bird it's
your first tattoo Wow man when you said
you were gonna get a real rejects tattoo
I imagined it to be much smaller this is
I think this is literally the first real
rejects tattoo that exists I think so
with that in mind I would like to
announce we were actually changing our
logo yep in a couple hour was hiring
this one and change your name altogether
yeah we're not getting called real
rejects anymore it's gonna be called
Greg and Josh there's no logo just the
texts maybe there's a way you can get it
returned if you need to buddy we're
actually gonna do some sponsored shout
outs for this laser tattoo removal and
if you use our special offer code you
can get 15% off your tattoo yeah I
talked with Eric
pretty much most days of the week we
have a pretty lengthy message exchanges
back and forth there's someone I've
really gotten to know pretty well well
people talk stuff you know a lot people
say stuff I do not really think you
would go through with this is the fact
that you did is a true honor may have
touched yeah thank you so much man
what's your lookin buff in this picture
here yeah you're looking great
yeah man God I mean you talk about
manscaping and the hashtags but I mean
like there's there's a good amount of
arm for you to put that on and now I'm a
little jealous saying I want to do it in
a mirror
ya know you can be on top I just wanted
you to be flexing that logo there I just
be looking at it the entire time make it
dance you know make it make the real see
ya and I just have that that that six
second intro song that we have just
playing the whole time on a Loutre get
it pump me to the beat man what if you
stop liking our channel I hope that we
always entertained you from now on I'm
just gonna attack vegan people the
entire time they want to live in Atlanta
I was gonna put I want to see if there's
a if we can destroy our reputation so
much we can get you to try to turn it
into a Tyra magnet symbol yeah I think
you could easily touch that up into a
Tyrone if you needed to you know I
remember who created to the guy who
created the original logo we had just
the members years ago we had a very few
brief exchanges on the internet never
met in person you know if I saw her face
before there was a fan art then we turn
it into our logo and my computer has
crashed so many times I have lost so
many things off of it crashing but if
you happen to have that original email
send it my way
so I can properly credit you buddy I've
spent time wondering about that because
I was also like you know what's the
legality of that
well someone set the logo to us they
designed the logo and then someone on
top of that maybe the animator I could
find the email it's a few years old
they're watching get ready to get a
lawyer
yeah yes it's gonna be just like Mike
Tyson hangover 3 that's beautiful man
you look great in that photo oh god
you're nice and hairy
this means a hell of a loss this means
that yeah man I like you so much and
that logo came around on this channel I
remember that you're the bomb I adore
the living hell out of you man I'm kind
of speechless right now I know that I'm
just staring at this and trying to
commit the idea this is rid of my
feelings yeah how do you feel
do you regret this I mean it's
we'll cuz in a way it's a responsibility
because now I'm like we got to always do
justice to this tattoo - this guy
specific today it's Herrick Norseman
yeah cuz the old channels maybe revolved
around him now I know you you you've got
our emblem in your body like a huge
honor and and i'll so yeah
responsibility but if you implied for
the page rampage this means nothing
yeah you will denounce you sayonara
unofficial whatever it's a lot of guys
say yeah our love is very conditional on
you being pledged to this anywho Eric
love you buddy this is this is crazy a
saint as strictly being criticized this
is ballsy trippy balls trippy that's
your new rapping name balls trippy on
the mic you know what I feel worthy
thanks you rock thanks Eric
and we deserve this we earned I'm gonna
play that a whole like what did we do to
deserve this
nah we deserve it frankly y'all should
have gotten real rejects ETSU's a long
time ago should be there's only one it
should be required to pledge to the
patreon that you have a real rejects
tattoo beforehand I'll get a tattoo are
you yeah really
where you gonna get it flippin you gotta
get to real rejects logos one over each
nipple why would I do that
you do that I why would I do that why
would I do that cuz you're the nipple
chills guy you could have your nipple
poking out from like the center hole
it's you got the bigger nipples I don't
know if that's true hey dude
you got the bigger nipples so we're
talking about grown-up always all the
nowadays better naps sleeping over
talking you about each other's new
parents sizes getting out of Amalur and
measuring them you know the big nips
calculating the circumference is
diameter rig I get chills but they're
not big ok current perhaps this is true
III feel like this is true information
see